my name is AMJ mad and I'm the
co-founder and CEO of repet repet is the
fastest way to go from an idea to a
piece of software we provide everything
you need to write code and deploy it in
the cloud repet has integrated AI from
the moment you have an idea you can
describe that idea to the AI it can
generate code for you it'll help you
write that code make it better and
deploy it you know where is repet at we
have more than 25 million developers
registered worldwide we have people
going all the way from writing the first
line of code to building a business
making a lot of money and even selling
their businesses and most your users are
actually non nonwestern we see growth in
these countries kind of happen almost
all of a sudden it's interesting so
there's usually like one sort of
influencer or patient zero we're also
building a parall education system for
kids
learning programming by doing we also
have a bounty system where kids can earn
money by doing software tasks for people
and we have this program called The 100
days of code and if you can commit 20 30
minutes a day so as you're typing code
there's someone talking to you I mean
you had that experience you you put up a
bounty and the guy who did the Bounty
for you had just finished learning how
to code it's like skin in the game way
of of learning now ai is another
foundational technology it's as big if
not bigger than the internet itself so
if you have idea you have a spark of
inspiration just over repet you don't
even have to start typing any code just
talk to the AI and you can generate some
code and get get a quick prototype up at
repet we're going all in on open- Source
AI as a parallel ecosystem because we
think AI is a core part of the modern
software stack it's really about
democratizing access to to programming
this is a talk for the network State
Conference